[Music]
boomba is an iconic character within
Dragonball and one of the most well
known characters across the planet there
are tons of people that identify Bulma
as a beacon of female empowerment and
others who disagree I happen to fall
somewhere in the middle and honestly I'm
only interested in discussing her role
as it's written within the story the
Japanese anime industry has enjoyed a
long history of success and worldwide
acclaim for the most part but something
I've always kept an eye out for while
watching and reading these series has
been their female characters and how
they fit within the story many often
times reduced to rather cliche and
boring things such as eye candy someone
to save or as someone's affection to be
one now I understand that this is an
incredibly divisive topic and simply by
the nature of it will be incredibly
personal to a lot of people despite my
best efforts to groan and focus this
video analysis in narrative theory with
that said while I will largely be
speaking from a story perspective I will
be giving opinions on the topic here and
there when it's needed to further the
discussion I'm not looking to infer
anything about who she might be as a
person just what she offers the series
as it's written by Akira Toriyama
the very same way I looked at Jordans
imasu I want to see how her character
has served the plot today I will be
dissecting and analyzing one of the
oldest and most iconic female characters
to come out of Japan today I will be
breaking down the brash the beautiful
and the genius Bulma
[Music]
I really like Bulma as a character I'm
sure there are nostalgic reasons that
play in my mind to create this opinion
but from a narrative point of view as a
personality I think she's easily one of
the most standout and memorable in the
series for better or worse and whatever
your opinion of her it's impossible to
deny that you know exactly what she's
like even if you've only had limited
exposure to her and that's terrific
characterization with that said I do
have some critiques the first being
would have the most common throughout
fiction and that is that she's
essentially a plot device now I know
that implies she's a husk of a character
made to fulfill a specific function
within the story and while she is much
more than that both for great and
terrible reasons which I'll get to later
I do think that she is a plot device
within the show in fact I'd even go as
far as to say that she is primarily a
plot device by design but I'm getting a
little ahead of myself here
what's a plot device in storytelling the
goal is to move from one key moment to
the next as seamlessly as possible until
the conclusion of the narrative has been
reached oftentimes the story's
characters can get into circumstances
that brings the stories forward momentum
to a screeching halt and so if we keep
that in mind a plot device is an object
or character in the story whose purpose
is purely to drive the plot forward
maintaining its flow or resolving
situations within it it could be
something everybody wants to obtain a
device that must be destroyed or an
annoying teenager who must be protected
at all costs I did not write this
definition I found it online and it's as
if it was written specifically to make
the point that Bulma fits the role
perfectly at the very beginning of the
story she is the character that
introduces Goku the main character to
the Dragon Balls and the wider world
through the use of her intelligence and
gadgets she bridges the gaps in the plot
were necessary transporting our heroes
and solving the problems the plot
produces such as space traversing and
even time travel she is also quite often
the subject of multiple kidnappings and
countless rescues now can a character be
a plot device and compelling at the same
time well yeah absolutely
Walter White being a chemistry teacher
is in some form a plot device that
enables the story being told to flow
comfortably however in his case he is a
great character first and a plot device
second so what makes a great female
character this
is a question that's getting asked more
and more frequently in recent years as
we strive for less would note female
characters and honestly it's a strange
one to me the answer to what makes a
good female character is the exact same
as what makes a good character period
now the answer to this isn't exactly
easy to pin down but in general if you
want to twist my arm for a definition a
good character to me at least is one
that breeds interest within the story
they exist Walter White is a compelling
character that emphasizes the best
attributes of Breaking Bad
god damn right eren yeager facilitates
the most interesting outcomes in attack
on Titan Goku is a perfect catalyst for
wonderful things to happen in Dragon
Ball and awful things to happen in
Dragon Ball super yeah yeah yeah yes so
what did bulla bring to the table for
this story well a friend of mine took
time to ask a few of her friends and
other female Dragon Ball fans in the
community what their take was on the
character this is what they had to say
at the beginning Bulma Zoli motivation
was to have a boyfriend she was willing
to use her looks to get what she wanted
while manipulating those around her she
was incredibly capable and still is
proving herself proficient with tech
more so than any other character which
was interesting because in a show that
revolves around guys that rely on their
physical prowess to get ahead how can a
female role come into play that isn't
just the strong girl characters like
Vidal and chichi began as fighters or
physically strong characters within the
story but sort of lost relevancy within
the narrative due to lack of utility
bull de never had such a problem which
is sort of interesting because back in
the early 80s when this story was
written in both the west and the east
female characters were very much prizes
to be won by the hero mild-mannered
SWE's and in a lot of ways helpless so
for the time that she was introduced
boomers character having any edge to her
at all with any abilities was in many
ways a win in the direction of strong
female character writing she doesn't
want nor has she ever wanted a
stereotypical life she might have wanted
in the beginning to get a cute boyfriend
but it's a selfish desire of hers and
changing her mind on that was the arc
her character underwent in the beginning
chichi and Videl both get pregnant and
seemed to solely focus on their kids and
lose a lot of what made their characters
have more of that focus in the story
originally we
was their ability to face however since
Pumas strength lies with her smarts and
her sexuality
she doesn't have to necessarily give
that up as much after becoming a mother
I mean boomers showing up in the Android
saga as a single mother was a massive
deal that's not a thing that's done in
Japan and certainly wasn't back then and
that's just one aspect of boomers
character people can relate to even
today a lot of female fans who love
Dragon Ball Z as a teen have to deal
with what she's experiencing right now -
we're all getting older some of us have
kids and despite it being played for
laughs
when the brouilly movie and even battle
of gods drew attention to boomers aging
I was honestly amazed because you never
talk about aging in Japan there's a
saying there about women who are
Christmas cakes no one wants you after
the 25th meaning if you're not married
by 25 your scene is past your prime
honestly there's a lot to be said about
sexuality and its use in media and of
course each culture has its own unique
sexuality issues and morals Japan just
happens to have some of the most
interesting concerning sexuality and you
have to take into account the lingering
dampening effects of a less progressive
and more traditional Society of which
Japan while definitely making progress
is still very much operating under is
boma still used as a sex object
of course her body is always on display
and with her sexuality and appearance
being part of her strength aging from a
narrative point of view is an
interesting part of her plotline which
is something about her character I would
love to see come more into play as the
show continues the guys in the show get
to stay the same for the most part their
strength only expands but the very area
boma relied on to give her some of her
strength her body as an object of desire
is now aging and how she deals with that
could be really interesting seeing as we
never got to see that for me personally
the story should always come first an
easing extra should be left out if a
character isn't serving a purpose by
conducting themselves it has seen the
way that they are it only serves to
bring the story down this is why I'm not
a fan of fanservice others love it and
many are different to it I think there's
a time and place for everything and from
the shows I've seen very few choose
their moments tastefully the most
irritating part about this for me is
what could have been bull muff from
Future Trunks as timeline has a story
more interesting than that
which we got from black and Zuma sue got
an emotional level at least anyway in
her troubled timeline her genius is the
most valuable trait as it's the only one
that can bring about victory which plays
into the Dragon Ball formula of
progression through struggle her
struggling to get the parts and feel
necessary to travel back in time to
change the fate of that timeline and to
maybe see the person she loves one more
time that's a compelling emotional story
that wasn't touched on nearly enough in
the original koku black arc or even in
the Android saga it wasn't brought up at
all in the anime and was only briefly
touched on during Toyota Rose manga you
have a character that's understood by
the audience
intimately and you never utilized them
to their fullest potential now I'm not
suggesting an arc centred around boomers
antics by any means but she definitely
had more to add to that story than that
which was shown and I honestly think a
lot was left on the table that wasn't
embraced look my intention for this
video is not to act as yet another
mindless voice talking about
representation into the void of the
internet and I'm definitely not someone
that thinks people can't think for
themselves because a movie or TV show
tells them or doesn't tell them how to
feel but instead this video was made to
offer to the best of my abilities an
explanation as to where I think and
others think there are opportunities
being norge and aspects that deserve
appreciation opportunities for better
and more emotionally rich stories that
make the most of their characters I
personally want opportunities for better
and more emotionally rich stories that
make the most of all of their characters
and honestly there are very few
characters as real and is fully realized
as Bulma in asking around for opinions
on her character one aspect offer that
many ladies mentioned was how real she
felt in a show full of people who
literally couldn't be real here she is a
very real human being as flawed and
emotional as any of us almost anyone
else in the main story has something
about them that could never actually
occur three eyes their strength tails
sneezing related mental disorders flying
I suppose one could say that inventing
capsule technology is not real and yeah
I guess I see that but the idea behind
that advantage is knowledge and
technology those are real things if I
wanted to I could try and become as
proficient an engineer as she is
supposed to be but no matter how hard
anyone
they will never be able to achieve what
Goku has heck even Vegeta can't do it
and he's as unbelievable as he is so I
asked are we getting the most emotional
stories from bulma's character that we
can know most definitely not is there
perhaps a lack of enthusiasm from Japan
to push in this direction I would
personally think so and I think that's
the biggest problem many female
characters and fans of those characters
have trouble with today however despite
this there's certainly no denying that
bullet is a fantastic character with
arguably just as much if not more
personality than any other character in
the series which is why I wanted to
write this video in the first place all
the stories that could have been told
but never were and some that we
hopefully might hear in the not so
distant future thanks for watching
[Music]